these people are not motivated by money
you know a couple million here a couple
million there Bill Gates isn't going to
notice but if you threaten to tell his
wife that he's been you know porking
some kid
that'll go ahead and get some compliance
and obedience out of him and that's what
it's I think that that's the reason why
Epstein's dead and I think that's the
reason why the list never came out the
people that have been to Epstein Island
because they're all probably scummy
people that have a lot that had a lot of
dirt or that I've seen had a lot of dirt
on them and that's what kept them you
know in line I think that there are
there are very powerful people that have
a lot of dirt on people with a lot of
money I couldn't help but notice in that
I think it was a PBS interview with Bill
Gates you see that one where he's like
well he's dead so you know I always say
but here's the thing when he goes he
says she says did was did you learn a
lesson here and he goes well he's dead
now so you know you always got to be
careful and he's like holding back a
smile